I want to be married I want to be
engaged to my beautiful girlfriend
Madison I want to be a good father a
good role model a strong role model
Aaron Carter opens up exclusively to ET
about his love for girlfriend Madison
Parker the professional photographer has
been by his side through thick and thin
including the singers July 15th DUI
arrest I met on Instagram she wanted to
do a shoot with me and I thought she was
beautiful so I believe FaceTime for
three days and then when I got home to
LA I took her out to dinner I told him I
was like you're one of the only guys
that have ever courted me I love you I'm
happy and so the guy I'll give him I'll
give him a shot okay instantly saw that
he had the biggest heart ever he's
amazing he's so funny
the couple says they're open to filming
a reality show would you ever put your
lives and your engagement in marriage
and wedding on TV absolutely maybe we
should call it welcome back Bonnie and
Clyde where do you see your life with
Aaron and 10 years from oh baby yeah
we're gonna have lots of babies how our
daughters be my daughter
yeah I know he's gonna be cool no I'm
gonna teach him hopefully but I'm gonna
teach him how to be sure but I
definitely won't let him now at Aaron's
party let me tell you and he will not be
getting any candy only on Halloween
[Music]
you